bonjour bilal bonjour pauline et dans la
presse ce matin là d'historique promise
par joe biden à l'ukraine c'est le
guardian britannique qui ont fait sa une
un ce vendredi joe biden répond menace
de vladimir poutine en doublant son aide
à l'ukraine le président américain vous
l'avez évoqué un peu plus tôt a demandé
une rallonge de 33 milliards de dollars
au congrès dont une vingtaine de
milliards à eux seuls seraient consacrés
à l'envoi des armes en ukraine jobs
hayden justifie sa demande ainsi le
journal le site les etats-unis ne
peuvent pas rester à l'écart face aux
atrocités et à l'agression russe alors
la russie qui a bombardé kiev tandis que
le secrétaire général des nations unies
étaient sur place absolument et toujours
le guardian qui développe cette
actualité puisque le journal britannique
un reporter sur place à kiev ce reporter
site antonio goûter res je ne suis pas
choqué parce que ce bombardement a eu
lieu alors que je suis là mais parce que
kiev est une ville sacrée pour les
ukrainiens mais aussi pour les russes et
ça ça renvoie à quoi ça renvoie au fait
que kiev et a vu naître le premier état
russe au moyen-âge et c'est d'ailleurs
l'un des arguments un des arguments
pardon principaux de vladimir poutine
pour justifier le fait que selon lui la
russie et l'ukraine serait le même pays
peut-être villa le cercle indice de plus
qui montrerait que l'armée russe
piétinent en ukraine la société wagner
abaisse ses critères de recrutement le
figaro nous propose ce décryptage titré
comment la société wagner a abaissé
critères pour recruter des mercenaires
en masse c'est important sur les réseaux
sociaux russes les campagnes de
recrutement se multiplient et ne
s'embarrasse plus des faux semblants
habituel nous rapporte le journal les
salaires ont augmenté de 1900 euros par
mois ils atteignent parfois 2800 euros
par mois c'est conséquent et dans le
même mouvement les critères de sélection
physique eu sa baisse à tel point que
certaines annonces précises même je cite
on ne regarde pas les dents c'est une
une sacrée précisera les libérations de
son côté fait saine
sur l'union des gauches tout à fait avec
une avec un titre en forme de voeux
pieux à la une pour le quotidien de
gauche français ils titrent gauche au
pluriel
réconciliables voilà on voit cette une
est le journal ou vendent ou bleu pâle
sur le titre l'union enfin une priorité
à gauche ah oui alors ça c'était au cas
où on n'avait pas bien compris le
message de la une alors il s'agit bien
sûr des négociations en cours entre la
france insoumise de jean-luc mélenchon
et les divers partis de gauche pour
faire une liste commune aux élections
législatives et l'article fait un point
sur ce qui les rassemble à ce stade et
ce qui les divise toujours est justement
le parti socialiste lui est divisé en
son sein sur ce rassemblement et
libération nous offre un petit encadré
avec un florilège de citations en
interne pour illustrer l'ambiance qui
règne au parti socialiste en ce moment
alors la première tout le monde veut
tuer le ps c'est normal nous on a tué
tout le monde la deuxième anne hidalgo
ma gueule et dessus pendant 12 minutes
et enfin la dernière qui écoutent encore
françois hollande rien dans le figaro
c'est d'un autre rassemblement qu'il
s'agisse celui aux tourrades emmanuel
macron c'est le chant des courtisans un
grand classique des début de quinquennat
selon le figaro c'est donc un champ qui
est entonné à l'unisson par tout un tas
de personnalités politiques des
flatteurs comme les appelle le journal
dès l'annoncé de la victoire du
président réélu alors c'est un article
un peu caustique qu'évoquent les
félicitations publiques et enflammé sur
twitter de députés jusque là inconnu en
passant par le téléphone d'emmanuel
macron qui croule sous les messages de
félicitations signé signé pourquoi parce
qu'ils sont envoyés par des gens qui n'a
pas dans son répertoire ou enfin cet
outsider qui s'est glissée au premier
rang des cérémonies de félicitations en
train d'applaudir bien devant les
caméras un certain manuel valls un
ancien ministre du parti socialiste
allait enfin nous allons parler un peu
de mode et de gastronomie alors
j'imagine pauline que vous connaissez
kfc on voyait bien sûr c'est assez de
fast-food kiki van der burgh des ailes
de poulet ou tout à fait tout à fait
c'est exactement ça et bien le film
tonnes poste nous apprend ce vendredi
que kfc et sort un sac à main alors
accrochez vous parce que ce sac à main
vaut 100 fois le prix du sandwich en
magasin voilà on le voit ici 20 sandwich
coûte aux alentours de 2 euros 1 chez
kfc ce sac lui en coûte 200 mais alors
vous en avez pour votre argent puisque
ce sac a été design et a été conçue
exactement au format du sandwich que
propose la chaîne voilà de quoi
transporter c'est chicken wings avec
classe et élégance un but voilà mais
c'est sûr que c'est très pratique de
beau de mettre ça dans un sac en cuir
une assemblée et aborde merci de nous
avoir parlé merci pour cette revue de
presse